So let's start off by looking at
affine transformation as an example of
something we want to understand and
figure out all the parameters for.
This would be an equation,
we would basically have these eight
parameters that would change to
create an affine warp which basically
means is now have an image like this.
Which after transformation or
warping would appear to be this way.
So an affine transformation basically we
are combining linear transformations,
the ones we looked at, that were
the you know the rotation scaling and
all of that stuff, with translations.
So in essence, this this image
is now moved over here and
it's also been warped.
[SOUND] The properties of an affine
transformation are that origin does not
necessarily map to origin.
For example, this could be
the original origin of this image,
we've translated it and then morphed it.
Lines map to lines if you notice,
all lines are still lines here.
They've just changed a little bit but
they're still lines.
And similarly,
parallel lines all remain parallel.
These are the basic properties
of affine transformations.
And one thing, if you noticed,
this could be achieved by actually
modeling these six parameters.
So, parameters a, b, c, d,
e, f, I have six parameters.
So in essence this is a six degree
of freedom on our presentation and
once we do this now,
we can actually figure out the
transformation going from here to there.